vous vous quand vous étiez en couple
vous vous faisiez l'amour combien de
fois par semaine par exemple par semaine
ou par jour gilbert désveaux vous posez
votre question vous herbe au soir cyril
hanouna de dauphiné libéré
lorsque souvent possible avec la même
toujours non mais elle comme rennes mais
ça va pas non elle peut plus accuser
tout le temps donc et sam était dingue
ou quoi seul nom il craque pas oui c'est
un bon comédien
oui deux fois par semaine par ce même
col améliorer le bosse beaucoup
jeudi matin dimanche matin samedi matin
dimanche à temps il me soit 1 de ce
qu'est la loupe à téléfoot jeu avant le
badminton ça met en condition avant
pendant après si c'est ça qui peut
déjouer précise tous les samedis et au
je me lève à 3h du matin
semaine sinon c'est vendredi solvay
socha et le reste
[Applaudissements]